I have 96 payments on this Public
service loan
forgiveness uh with the goal being
120 for the program um I kind of had
that planned for since I graduated in
2014 didn't think too much about it had
a bunch of Life Changes take place and
now I have uh almost enough to pay off
the student loans and I'm considering
paying those off now instead of waiting
for the Public service loan forgiveness
was it 97% of the loans that followed
the student loan forgiveness program
have not been forgiven they've only
forgiven less than
3% and so if you have a 97% chance that
your plan's not going to work the reason
I was son I just told you three out of
100 don't argue with this